hey everyone developer here and well i
can't lie to you i'm still left in like
absolute shock after what happened
throughout this arc it's like trying to
physically hold myself back from
continuing past the 40th chapter which
i've completely and utterly failed in
but moving on this arc here is the
fourth installment in tatsuki fujimoto's
story and like the main character denji
we finally come face to face with
another half devil human hybrid which
results in some truly heroising moments
the battles in the story all multiply in
its intensity and it really starts
giving us a true insight into how broken
our souls will be by the time that we
actually finish the series so grab some
melons and sit back as we go over the
one and only katana man arc of chainsaw
man as per usual though all your lovely
humans make sure you grab a baseball
bear and start backheely bassing up that
like button for me plus if you are new
around here and want to watch more anime
explain content just like this then make
sure to follow through with that bat on
the subscribe button but anyway enough
of that let's get into chainsaw man
while in a ramen shop denji himeno aki
and power all eat meanwhile various 4th
division agents from the previous
night's drinking attend to their duties
in various locations throughout the city
as they do all the civilians around them
pull out guns and gun shots are heard
ringing out the group inside the ramen
shop hears the gunshots but they assume
that they're merely drum beats a
stranger on the table next to them then
speaks up insulting the quality of the
ramen dingy and power are both offended
by this and their man comments on their
peers unrefined palette remarking that
those who do not eat much in their youth
gain a poor sense of taste sensing
something wrong aki asks to leave the
man continues though discussing his
beloved grandfather whom would often
spoil him he then reveals his
grandfather to be the old man who was
possessed by the zombie devil he accuses
denji of the old man's death before
stating the gun devil wants your heart
he pulls out a gun and shoots dingy in
the head before shooting himino in the
chest and arky in the arm before he can
continue though power punches him
knocking the gun out of his hand aki
then summons the fox devil to devour the
man he then worriedly looks at dingy's
unmoving body as well as amino's
critically injured state the fox devil
then suddenly informs him that the man
was neither human nor devil before it is
torn apart from the inside the man
re-emerges revealing himself to be a
devil-human hybrid fused with the katana
devil aki orders power to stop hamino's
bleeding as he pulls out his sword aki
unleashes his sword and power is
surprised to see that it resembles a
nail rather than a blade katana man
starts swinging atom but aki dodges
before reading in his blade as he shouts
fire an off-panel devil is shown
flicking the nails point into the katana
man a disembodied mouth is then seen
sounding their number three katana man
hesitates before swinging again aki once
again dodges shouting fire once more and
passing the katana men again again the
disembodied voice speaks saying the
number two aki makes a final lunge
passing the katana man's belly and the
voice states one
the katana man knocks aki back showing
confusion over aki's plan aki however
calls the devil out to finish him
revealing it to be the cursed devil as
the devil states zero and massive
disembodied hand is shown to grab the
katana man he briefly expresses shock
before being torn limb from limb by the
giant skeletal devil he falls to the
floor unconscious and bleeding profusely
aki calls out to power who recommends
getting hamino a doctor aki is shocked
by the use of a gun in the man's ominous
statement regarding the gun devil
suddenly a young woman appears
commenting on the cursed devil's power
as aki asks whether she is working with
a katana man she steps forward and picks
him back up the girl named sawatari asks
the katana man why he lost torchy
ashamedly responds he let down his guard
she orders him to kill the group quickly
leading the katana man to lunge forward
at aki before he can respond his chest
is suddenly slashed by the katanas aki
heavily injured by the attack falls to
the floor sawatari comments on how the
wounds are likely non-fatal due to the
devil hunter's suits being reinforced
hemino tells power to forget her and
help aki however power refuses believing
herself to be far outmatched hemino
attempts to summon the ghost devil but
it refuses out of fear of sarwatari as a
last resort to save aki himuno offers
her everything to the ghost devil the
devil's grimace quickly turns to a smile
as its true giant form is revealed the
ghost devil attacks the katana man with
each attack hemino loses more of her
body as she does this she thinks about
aki and remarks on how unusual it is
that he was still able to cry as most
devil hunters grow emotionally stunted
over time as aki looks at her she tells
him not to die as she wants someone to
be able to cry over her death sawatari
summons the snake devil ordering it to
devour the ghost devil it does leaving
nothing left of amino aside from her
clothes sawatari and the katana man turn
to dingy stating that their goal is to
take his heart as they say this the
ghost devil's dying hand is seen
floating towards dingy's body it pulls
the cord on his chest reawakening and
transforming him into his chainsaw form
though he is confused by the current
situation he instantly recognizes the
katana man and sarwatari as enemies
excitedly charging at them stating that
he loves bad guys as no one cares how he
brutally kills them salwatari noting she
is missing fingernails calls for backup
over a walkie-talkie she looks at aki
who was in shock over himino's fate
denji and the katana man continue
fighting with the katana man showing the
ability to slash large areas with a
single strike two backup agents arrive
firing guns at denji though he is shot
he is able to knock both down and takes
one as a hostage angrily the katana man
slices through both of them cutting them
in half at a speed denji was unable to
register picking up dingy's top half the
katana man orders the other agents to
get to a car remarking that the other
members of the fourth division are
likely dead due to the human
vulnerability to guns the scene cuts
showing the corpses of awry fushi hamino
makima and the two other hunters who
were at the drinking party in makima's
train carriage the assassins plan to
blend in with the civilians however they
are interrupted by makima standing up
who was somehow miraculously survived at
the station two hunters cross and tendo
wait they are shocked to hear news of
makima's death before seeing her step
out of the train in front of them
makima informs them of the attack as
they remark on these similar attacks in
tokyo they note their blood on her
clothes but she tells them that she was
not hit during the gun fight as she
dodged every bullet
inside the train we find the bodies of
the train assassins each of them with
gaping holes in their chests
moving forward makima theorizes that the
gun agents are going after denji she
orders kuros nintendo to find her a
shrine with a high elevation and 30
criminals with life sentences as well as
a change of clothes
elsewhere the gun agents begin to move
dingy's top half into a car as they do
one begins to sweat remarking how
strange he feels in an instant he is
flattened by an invisible force
horrifying his compatriots panicked
sabatari calls the team e asking them to
confirm makima's death with c team and a
team agent responds commenting that
they've lost contact with sea team
however he is too flattened mid-sentence
elsewhere at the shrine makima enacts a
ritual tendo and kuros as well as 30
prisoners are blindfolded tendu informs
corrose that due to her high ranking the
nature of the devil magima has a
contract with is kept classified makima
orders a prisoner to say the name
mishima shuzo he complies the gun agent
named mishima shuzo is instantly
flattened afterwards the prisoner then
falls dead as makima instructs the next
prisoner to say another name and so on
and so on throughout the entire country
multiple gun agents are constantly
flattened suddenly makima stops making
it instructs carouse entendo to take off
their blindfolds telling them that she
has done all she can do from their
current location
panicked to the situation and people
dying around her sarwatari orders the
katana man to move denji before makima
can interfere further as he does he
suddenly sees a figure moving towards
them which is kabini clutching a knife a
flashback shows they whilst on duty
together arai was shot by an elderly gun
agent in his last moments he threw
himself in front of kabini shielding her
from being killed as well kavini asks
sawatari and the katarda man whether
they are gun agents and unnerved
sabotage summons the snake devil's tail
to attack her she swiftly dodges it
though before running along its body
towards the pier before the katana man
could shoot at her she deftly slices his
arm off grabs the gun and shoots him in
the back she then turns her aim to
sabotari sabotari fires at her but she
uses dingies reinforced chains her head
to deflect the bullet samutari grabs the
katana man and drags him into the car
driving away kumini looks down at
denji's unconscious torso and apologizes
for trying to kill him in the past she
slowly begins to laugh growing slowly
hysterical as she remembers a rise dead
body before deciding she plans to tell
hermino that she quits
at a similar time arriving in tokyo
makima is greeted by madoka he informs
her that almost every agent in divisions
one through four were killed he states
that the orders from the top of the
organizations and that all divisions
will be merged and placed under mahima's
control the news causes her to smile
calmly madoka anticipating a coming
conflict quits on the spot as he leaves
he asks makima one more thing
how much of the events she had
anticipated but she merely responds that
she is unable to share classified
details with a civilian awakening in a
hospital bed aki turns to see denji and
power at his bedside
reading manga and arguing over airpoles
aki asks who of the fourth division
survived was dingy responding that only
kabini and madoka made it but madoka had
instantly quit dingy and power then
turned to leave as they were summoned by
makima however noting aki's quiet
despondence dingy leaves him an apple
now alone in his room aki and sheesh the
cursed sword and asks the cursed devil
how long he has to live it responds that
he is two years aki then picks up a
cigarette however remembering himeno he
drops it and breaks down crying outside
the room denji looks through the window
hoping to collect the manga that he had
left in there he begins to walk away
before suddenly realizing that despite
his attachment to himino her death has
not caused her to cry or feel any real
sadness he thinks back to the sadness he
felt after pochita's death and realizes
that neither power nor aki's death would
make him cry
he thinks that even if mahima were to
die though he would be depressed for a
short while he would get over it
surprisingly quick troubled by these
thoughts he wonders if giving his heart
to a devil truly robbed him of his
humanity resolving not to think about
such depressing topics he and power
leave to meet with makima as they do
tendo and carose enter aki's room to
instruct him regarding the changes to
the fourth division meanwhile makima
explains the denji and power that the
bureau believes enemy forces are
targeting denji specifically as such
they have prepared a training course for
the two of them she begins to introduce
them to kishibe but is interrupted by
him he asks them of their thoughts when
their comrades died to which they state
that they pretty much felt nothing he
then asks them of their desire for
revenge which they both re-buff lastly
he asks them whether they're loyal to
humans or devils to which they both
respond whomever will give them their
best deal hearing this kishibe expresses
a satisfaction with their responses he
steps forward and puts his arms around
denji and powell's shoulders stating
that their training has started makima
turns to leave eskashibe explains that
he is a devil hunter working with a
special first division and asks that
they call him master he then informs the
pair that he enjoys booze woman and
killing devils before he begins to
calmly choke the two of them then snap
their necks kashibe drops power and
genji to the floor explaining that their
basic body structures are identical to
humans and as such he snapped their
necks paralyzing them he then gives them
blood explaining that unlike humans it
is all they need to recover from most of
their injuries kishibe explains that he
is the strongest devil hunter and as
such he believes that in order to train
the two of them they need to reach a
point where they can beat him in a
confrontation deji and power move
towards him preparing to fight however
khasheba swiftly stabs denji in the head
and back before slicing powell's throat
he comments on the inhuman intuition to
try and attack him without a moment of
hesitation he states that since he was a
child he always hoped for a toy that
wouldn't break before promising to turn
the pair into the baddest of the
badasses
meanwhile in his hospital beard aki is
surprised to find he is unable to summon
khan kuros remarks that the devil is
likely angry for being killed and as
such likely to never respond to him
again
tendu asks of aki's lifespan after using
the cursed devil but he interrupts and
asks of their intentions with him they
reveal that due to the worsening of the
devil crisis and massive losses to the
organization the bureau intended to
request he makes a deal the massively
powerful devil to help gain an advantage
they then give him the choice to quit
and live in a more peaceful life however
he refuses
seeking revenge against the gun devil
for killing his family and the gun
agents for killing himino
as kuros and tendo leave an unseen woman
enters surprising haki
that night kishiba decides to stop the
training so that he can go home and
sleep dingy collapses from exhaustion as
power gives him some of her blood to
heal him the pair walk home bloodied and
tattered power comments on how dingy
likely died 20 times and she was knocked
unconscious the same amount the two
consider running away with zinji
noticing that fighting without enjoying
himself is the worst suddenly power
suggests that rather than using brute
force they try and outsmart khasheba
causing the pair to grow excited and
remark that they feel smarter already
kishibi walks towards denji and power's
apartment annoyed at them for being late
to training from inside power smells his
presence as the pair now wearing glasses
moved to put this super genius strategy
into action power thrusts a sphere of
blood through the door however kishibe
intuitively dodges it on the floor above
the parrot place bottles of blood which
power uses to spare through the ceiling
above koshibay again koshibe blocks and
dodges them however denji drops down
behind him quietly hoping to hit him
with an axe however kishibe swiftly
kicks him in the head knocking him down
without even looking kishibe commends
them for their attempt stating it was
their best yet but points out that the
pair were weakened by power's massive
loss of blood and dingy's inability to
predict attacks he tells them that
they're done for the day however as
denji begins to relax he flings a knife
at him one in the duo that pray
shouldn't trust what a hunter says
meanwhile kuros and tendo take aki to
the bureau's devil holding facility they
remind him that making a contract with
these devils will entail heavy losses
however it will ultimately protect him
and they come in conflicts cross asks
about the girl who visited him in the
hospital to which aki reveals that she
was hermino's younger sister she gave
him a number of letters hamina had
written over the years many of which
discussed him in one highlighted passage
though we see that ximena had asked is
there anything that i can do to get aki
to quit which is something that shakes
him to his core
as they reach a chamber carrots reveals
that they intend for aki to make a
contract with a future devil they remark
on two previous agents who made a
contract with it one who gave up half of
their lifespan and the other who gave up
both of their eyes as well as their
sense of taste and smell
aki then enters the room and sees a
humanoid tree-like future devil emerged
from the shadows as it repeats the
phrase constantly the future is best the
future devil repeats phrases such as the
future rules and requests that argue
repeat them as well aki states his
intention of making a contract annoying
the devil the devil requests to read are
his future by placing his head in his
chest cavity as he complies the devil
begins giggling profusely and agrees to
the contract on the condition that he
can live in his right eye
aki is shocked by the easiness of the
request however the devil mockingly
informs him that it wants to see his
future with its own eyes as he will die
in the worst way possible it asks if he
wants to know how he will die however
aki refuses before agreeing to the
contract unfazed at all
meanwhile dingy and power lay beeson on
a floor kishibe comments on their
improvements and informs them that their
training will become weekly instead of
daily he wants them to keep a cool head
and remain aware of their surroundings
before informing them that their new
fourth division will be hunting sawatari
and the katana man khashebi informs them
that if the mission fails the fourth
division will be shut down and he'll be
forced to kill them denji heavily
remarks though that if they were to
fight he'd spare kishibe as thanks for
making him stronger and moving him
closer to the goal of deity makima later
kashubi sits down to drink with makima
he remarks his unhappiness with a
continuing dingy and powers training due
to his growing attachment towards them
he then questions mahima on his
pre-existing knowledge of the attacks
remarking that as long as she's on
humanity's side he'll look the other way
maki mistakes her goal as being to save
as many people as possible and increase
the prestige of the fourth division
kishibe considers this before calling
her a liar makima smiles eerily in
response in an office building the gun
agents reconvene planning to put their
leader into hiding salwatari points out
the pointlessness of hiding giving
mahima's power hearing this the katana
man agrees intending to kill denji with
his own hands so atari reveals the
group's ultimate weapon a cluster of
zombies left over by the zombie devil
elsewhere in a car as they drive aki
back home kuros asks him of his
intention to kill the gun devil he
states his annoyance commencing on the
ridiculous notion that a normal person
like aki could make any kind of impact
aki responds though that whilst the goal
is unrealistic he requires an
unrealistic outlook to make progress
crows tosses mikola saying that though
such an outlook irritates him he'll
still support it
meanwhile makima meets with a yakuza
boss he explains that though the gun
agents are members of his organization
he does not condone their actions he
elaborates that the factions were
influenced by sawatari who had had them
make small deals with the gun devil
paying money for guns and ammunition
magma requests the names of every yakuza
member who contacted the gun devil both
within the bosses group and his rivals
however the boss refuses explaining that
such a betrayal would cause all-out gang
warfare resulting in foreign mafias
invading japan he then calls the devil
hunters idiots without any real
education causing his compatriots to
laugh at makima makimedo places a small
bag on the table she explains as the man
looks within it that the eyeballs are
from all of the family members of every
person in this room as a boss looks in
horror makima offers to return them to
their owners in return for his
cooperation
a yakuza grunt swings at her however he
immediately collapses with blood pouring
from his face
meanwhile the special forces of the
bureau prepared to storm the gun agent's
building inside salwatari talks to the
katana man reaffirming their plan to
kill as many devil hunters as possible
and steal denji's heart kishibe orders
the hunters to storm the building as a
pack of zombies lion weight
below them koshiba introduces himself to
the second division leader firono and
police officer sheena who are in charge
of locking down the building he gives a
rundown of the various non-human members
of the special fourth division inside
the building the shark thing beam
appears and begins devouring these
zombies in his frenzy he accidentally
bites the violence fiend who knocks him
down before apologizing attacking more
zombies the violence fiend notices a
woman nearby and warns her to stay away
before realizing that she is also a
devil and is in fact the spider devil
she stands up and decapitates a zombie
whose head falls at the feet of the
angel devil who begins eating away at
the bodies aki appears and begins
cutting through the zombies the angel
devil asks saki for a hanky chief to
clean up some blood before explaining to
him that he absorbs others lifespans
through touch and is surprised at how
close aki has got him a gunman suddenly
appears and tries shooting at the two
but the angel deflects the bullet and
aki stabs him aki continues on his own
eventually coming face to face with
sawatari
she uses her stake devil to release the
ghost devil which is now subservant to
her
aki moves forward deflecting most of the
ghost devil's attacks for the future
devil's future side however he is
quickly overwhelmed by the many arms of
the ghost devil and is soon being
strangled by the creature in a flashback
he remembers an early meeting with
hamino and which she offered him a
cigarette however once she realizes that
he's underage she takes it back and
promises him to give it back to him when
he really needs to rely on something in
the present aki looks up having been
released from the ghost devil's grasp
from amongst its mass hamino's right arm
reaches out holding a cigarette taking
it ahi sees the words easy revenge
written across it
taking a deep breath he steps forward
remembering hermino's revise he reflects
that the ghost devil is blind and senses
its surroundings based on fear remaining
calm aki climbs a topic before promising
himino that he'll die soon then he
decapitates the ghost devil a shock
sabotary moves to summon the snake devil
but is stopped like a beanie holding a
knife to her throat aki orders kabini
not to kill her he then asks kabini why
she didn't quit the bureau to which she
awkwardly responds that she was close to
earning her bonus
dingy and power then arrive in the
headquarters using an elevator power
begins chomping on a severed zombified
hand disgusting dingy and causing the
two to scuffle as they argue the
elevator doors open revealing a swarm of
zombies in front of them due to the
zombies not noticing them dingy
recommends they stay quiet and utilize
the element of surprise power however
begins yelling loudly challenging the
zombies to combat power bravely steps
forward and begins fighting as a
bewildered and annoyed denji remains in
the elevator believing denji is still
watching her power easily slashes away
through dozens of hulking zombies
boasting that she is the strongest there
is
as denji's elevator arrives on the
highest floor he prepares to pull his
chainsaw's cord the door opens and he
sees the katana man alongside a pair of
gun agents the katana man asks him to
pause so we can ask a few questions he
explains the group's desire for
compensation over the old man's death
with denji frustratedly explaining that
the old man was zombified when the devil
killed him however he doesn't believe
this instead the katana man asks denji
whether he truly felt nothing when
killing the zombies reminding him that
they used to be humans denji though
repeats that he felt nothing
the katana man then reveals that despite
giving his heart to a devil unlike denji
he still feels guilt over killing
zombies explaining that dingy is the
only devil human hybrid without a sense
of conscience he requests dingy to
accept his death as a form of mercy
killing but denji casually responds that
he doesn't wanna and an irritated katana
man takes off his hand and becomes to
transform in front of him the two now
transformed crash through a wall and
begin falling towards the streets below
the katana men and denji still in combat
continue falling as denji is pushed away
he falls and lands atop a moving train
readjusting he is able to block an
attack from the still falling katana man
which sends them crashing into a crowded
carriage as floods of passengers flee a
voice over announces the train is coming
to an emergency stop denji notices a
remaining passenger an injured woman
lying on the floor as the katana man
launches an attack denji blocks her
protecting the woman but losing his arm
in the process the woman runs away as
then she angrily shout that they should
ban their move
the katana man then attacks again
slicing off denji's other arm he then
demands that as long as denji can no
longer fight he should apologize for
killing the old man and accept death
however denji refuses stating that as
long as he has his chainsaw on his head
he can still fight the two clash again
however the impact causes the blade on
denji's chainsaw head to shatter the
katana man again demands an apology in
return for a swift death but this time
denji reveals that the katana man was so
distracted with anger that he didn't
notice being sliced in half by denji's
leg the katana man now revealed to have
been split vertically reacts with a
moment of surprise before his body
completely falls apart into a mass of
blood and organs
watching then she repeats the words told
to him by kishibe pray should never
trust what a hunter says
a little while later and now outside the
stopped train the katana man now
reverted to human form and wearing
nothing but underwear awakens next to
the train bound by a set of chains or
blades
a shirtless denji stands over him
expressing his surprise over his speedy
recovery an infuriated katana man
threatens to kill him but denji rebuffs
it calling him a loser dingy states that
he is waiting for the police to come and
arrest him however he notes that he is
unwilling to accept the katana man
merely facing imprisonment after being
responsible for himino's death
as aki arrives then she announces he's
planning a tournament as revenge deji
asks saki if he'd like to join in on the
tournament stating that he shot himino
so his punishment should be nut shots he
then reveals the rules of his tournament
taking it in turns to kick the katana
man in his testicles with whomever can
make him scream the loudest before the
police arrive being crowned the winner
loudly sighing aki states it's not their
job to torture him and himino would be
unhappy with such actions however after
looking at the cigarette he was given by
the ghost devil he rolls up his sleeves
and asks about the reward for the winner
dingy responds and they get to keep the
remains of his testicles
somewhere across the city the remaining
gun agents are rounded up while the
angel devil looks into the distance
the scene returns to the katana man
screaming in pain as aki and denji
excitedly beat into him as he kicks him
aki thinks of himino stating that his
screams of pain are their requiem for
her elsewhere makima reports the events
of the date of the bureau
they question why the gun agents desired
denji's heart but makima reveals that
the snake devil killed salwatari before
she could be questioned likely as a part
of their contract makima reveals though
that with the gun devil's fragments
they've collected from the gun agents
they have a mass large enough to begin
indicating the location of the gun devil
that night dingy has a dream of standing
in front of a door he notes that the
dream is reoccurring from the other side
an eye looks in as pachita's voice
repeats his name
happily denji asks pachita to enter so
he can pet him however vegeta ominously
tells him to never open this door denji
then awakens in a cold sweat he looks
over and sees aki and power napping
beside him power is reawakened by dingy
shouts setting up and revealing that she
has grown several new horns commenting
on them power responds by punching him
the knock is powerful enough to send him
flying across the room and surprise the
both of them later on while observing
power's new enlarged horns makima
informs dingy that she has ingested too
much blood from the zombies and requires
some to be drained in order to decrease
her strength to make her less unruly
dingy agrees causing power to nervously
sweat makima reveals that walt's power
is busy he has been partnered with a
shark fiend called beam beam then
suddenly appears from the floor
attempting to hug dingy but a surprise
dingy knocks him down mucky mistakes
that beam has a distinct fondness for
dingy and has promised to follow any of
his orders noting dingy is in a bad mood
makima invites him out on a date
the next day denji excitedly waits for
her to arrive arriving several hours
early makima also shows up early and
reveals that the pair are going to have
a movie marathon at a local cinema
non-stop until midnight during the first
film then she notes that he isn't
laughing with the rest of the audience
looking at makima he sees that she is
not laughing either after the film
makima briefly critiques her commenting
on the plot and cinematography
the pair attend the next film and dingy
again notices that he and makima are the
only ones not reacting to the film
again as the film ends makima critiques
it the cycle continues throughout the
day with dingy growing continuously
bored before they enter the final film
denji comments that none of the films
had any impacts on him comey seen that
he may just not really get films making
responds that she is the same however
the very few that she did react to
changed her life as they view their next
film then she is shocked to find himself
crying at a seemingly trivial scene
looking at makima he sees she is also
silently crying the two then leave the
cinema and good spirits talking about
how they enjoyed the last film
then she questions makima as to whether
she believes he has a heart and in
response she leans in and listens to his
heartbeat before telling him that he
certainly does
she smiles and walks away leaving dingy
blushing in the middle of the street
well i guess that brings us to the end
of part 4 of tatsuki fujimoto's chainsaw
man obviously this part of the story has
like completely and utterly exploded and
just death and destruction and what the
[__] is actually going on right now
where is himino man like she just
disappeared like i don't even know what
to kind of take from the entire
situation i'm in the same state aki was
just crying in a crying out a bed the
whole time like the whole time this is
exactly how i'm feeling right now after
this like what's making my how how she
dodged all of these bullets on the train
like i'm trying to understand right now
what in the world is going on so i can't
wait to finally get into this next start
if you guys can hear there's a chainsaw
in the background so you know i thought
i thought it'd be different come outside
and everything but
some [__]
kids decided to in the middle of nowhere
start using his chainsaw to cut down
trees near a river but i you know i
guess i can't do too much about that i
hope you guys have enjoyed the video
obviously uh it's taken me a little bit
longer to put this one together than i
would have liked which is probably going
to be the case with the next up and
coming arcs as well as they just
gradually get longer uh these last three
arcs here so i'm super excited to
finally be able to read the bomb girl or
bomb devil arc now um
as far as i know
i think a [__] possum just ran down a
tree over there i heard something i'd
honestly there's so much noise out here
i really thought it was going to be
quiet and real peaceful and we could
chill out and i could do my outro here
and stuff but it's kind of just kind of
but anyway if you guys have enjoyed the
video make sure you leave a like on it
and if you are new around here make sure
you also hit that subscribe button as it
really helps out with pushing my stuff
to a bunch of new amazing people but
anyway enough of that for now it's been
your professional degenerate dear volo
and i will see you all in april bye
you